Mitchell:
Hi, everybody. Welcome.
This is the Geo fireside chat.
Um, we have, uh, six--
six of us up here onstage--
um, we'll do intros
in a moment--
and there are various other
Google folks scattered around,
um, who can also
answer questions.
So, um, uh,
I'll start with Peter.
Birch: [laughs]
Yes, I'm Peter Birch.
I'm the product manager
for the Google Earth API.
Mitchell: So my name's
Thor Mitchell.
I'm the product manager for
the Maps API and the Places API.
Raub: I'm Susannah Raub,
and I am the tech lead
on the Maps API in Sydney.
Madhavan: I'm Jayant Madhavan,
and I'm the tech lead
of the Fusion Tables team.
Shapley: I'm Rebecca Shapley.
I'm the product manager
for the Fusion Tables team.
Chu: And I'm Dan Chu.
I'm product manager for
our Geo Enterprise products.
Mitchell: So, uh, we were asked
just to give a-a sort of
brief 30-second summary of, um,
recent announcements,
stuff that's going on,
just to provide some context,
uh, and then we'll, uh,
we'll just move into
a sort of town hall-style Q&A.
Um, so on the Maps API side,
um, our big announcement
was yesterday morning.
Uh, we opened up the Places API
for general availability,
so anybody can go and, uh,
and sign up for a key for that,
and we also integrated, um,
Places into the Maps API,
so there are now, uh,
features in the Maps API
for searching for businesses,
and also, um, integrated
the Autocomplete functionality
that is on
the Google Maps Web site
into the Maps API,
so you can now attach that, um,
to any text field on a Web page
and get suggestions of--of
addresses and of businesses
as you type.
Um, uh, yeah.
Shapley: Um,
so with Fusion Tables,
we actually had, uh,
two exciting announcements,
one with the Maps API.
Um, you can now
do dynamic styling
as you use the data
from your Fusion Table
in a Fusion Tables layer
of the Maps API.
You can now request that
that data be styled.
Uh, you can change
the color of the polygons
or--or set the icon for
the points and things like that.
And you can do that dynamically
in your--in your Web page.
And we are also,
at the same time,
uh, opening
for our trusted testers
the ability to set the style,
uh, and the info window template
for a given table
through, uh, programmatically.
So that means that
if you're sort of preparing
a number of tables
to have the same--
to have the same look and feel,
that'll be easier now.
Birch: Uh, so on
the Earth side, um,
one thing I want to announce
is that--
so last year we were here
talking about how many people
actually have
the plug-in installed,
and we talked about, uh,
100 million computers out there
that, you know, had already
had the plug-in installed.
Uh, this year, uh,
I'm proud to announce
that there's now 150 million,
um, installs.
So that basically means that,
you know,
150 million computers out there
already have
the plug-in installed, you know.
And all the--although
the install flow
is very straightforward,
um, for many of the users,
especially the ones
who are gonna be, you know,
more likely to be using Earth
and Earth API,
um, it's already gonna be
installed there for you.
Um, the other thing
I should mention
is that, um, that's new
since last year
is that we now have a v3, um,
extension library,
so if that's kind of
one of those things
that was--was holding you back
from moving over to v3
or, uh, you know,
sort of part of your factor
in--in doing a v3,
that's something that, uh,
we're now supporting.
Mitchell: Okay, so--oh, yeah.
Chu: Yeah, I should probably
just quickly mention.
Well, this was announced
at Where 2.0.
One of the biggest things--
announcements
that we're excited about
is Earth Builder,
um, a great kind of
in-the-cloud way of kind of, um,
uploading and styling your, um,
map and vector and imagery data.
Um, and then also in terms of--
if we're looking kind of over
the course of the last year--
um, one of the exciting
partnerships we also had
with the Fusion Tables team
was, um, for
the Maps API Premier,
enabling kind of private,
uh, Fusion Tables layers,
uh, to be displayed.
So for many of you
who are familiar
with Fusion Tables layer,
quickly being able to display
data that you've stored
in a Fusion Table onto
an easy layer in the Maps API,
being able to have that
completely be private, uh,
as a Premier customer.
Mitchell: Okay, so we have
two microphones in the room.
We have a stand-up mic there,
and then we have
a roving mic here.
Um, this session
is being recorded,
so, um, please be aware of that
when you're asking questions,
and also please do wait
for the mic to arrive
before you start asking
your question.
Um...
man: So, um, if you're gonna ask
a question at that mic,
please just try and line up
directly behind that mic
so you're out of line of sight
of the--of the camera.
Mitchell: Yeah.
Okay, and with that...
Birch: Who's first?
Mitchell: [laughs]
man: I'm first.
Um, Fusion Tables--
um, I have a bunch of data
that I'd like to get out
on Fusion Tables
and get out to a map
and get it out to the public,
but I really don't want
the public
to get access
to the underlying data sets.
Um, should I be concerned
or not?
I'm--I'm not quite sure
what's going on there.
Chu: Well, you should be
concerned because we--
we have a solution for you,
right.
It's the, uh, the private
Fusion Tables layer.
We heard that feedback
from a lot of folks, right,
uh, that there's
a kind of balance in terms of
kind of how much access you want
others to have to your data.
So, uh, with the--I guess
just to elaborate
on the private Fusion Tables
layer, um, you can--
it sounds like you're already
familiar with the ability
to kind of quickly, you know,
reference your Fusion Table
and be able to display that.
In the past, you were--
you were basically referring
to the requirement
to make that table either public
or, um, kind of protected.
Um, now if you are,
along with Maps API Premier,
all you--there's basically
a dialog within Fusion Tables.
You can input your client ID,
which is kind of the key
that you're given as you--
when you sign up as
a Maps API Premier customer,
um, and then that allows you
to leave that table as private,
um, but still enjoy the benefits
of the Fusion Tables layer.
man: Okay, thank you.
man: Uh, my question is
kind of a follow-up to his.
Um, there--there are customers
that need to operate
in completely
disconnected networks,
but a lot of the technologies
that you guys
have been showcasing
is very, very exciting.
Is there any
kind of plans whatsoever
to introduce maybe
some of this technology,
with the Google Earth
Enterprise team,
um, bring some of these,
you know,
KML rendering especially,
to the Maps API
or, uh, Fusion Tables to--
on a smaller scale
to an Enterprise deployment
that needs to be completely
disconnected from the Web
on--on an internal network,
per se?
Birch: Um, so I'll take that.
So, I mean, absolutely.
I think there's a very
long history of, you know,
a lot of our customers,
especially Enterprise customers,
wanting to be able to work
in a disconnected environment.
And, you know, with the existing
Google Earth Enterprise
Earth client, uh,
that's completely
possible today.
Um, but with--
as the thing that Dan mentioned
with Earth Builder,
um, we're really starting
to bring a lot of these services
to the cloud and allow people
to kind of upload and connect
and serve that way.
But we also recognize the fact
that, you know,
some number of customers
are gonna want to also be able
to have a disconnected
experience like that.
So we don't have
anything specific
to announce right now on that,
but that is something
that we're definitely, you know,
very interested in,
and hopefully we'll have
more to talk about.
man: Okay. Thank you.
Birch: Do you want
to add anything?
Chu: I guess at the risk
of saying too much.
I would say, like, there's
probably two responses to that,
is continued kind of innovation
on the Earth Enterprise side,
like we are kind of continuing
to invest there
and kind of adding
functionality there.
Like Peter mentioned, it's--
there's some challenges, right,
with a completely
disconnected environment.
I think some things
that we've been brainstorming
is kind of like an intermediate
solution, really.
It's kind of more, um,
a solution that allows you
to be disconnected
most of the time
but still connect to the cloud
every once in a while.
And, um, that's, you know,
that's something we've been
brainstorming about,
not at all kind of
right around the corner yet.
man: Hi.
I wanted to ask a question
about Street View in v3.
I think this question
comes up a lot.
It's not quite as nice yet,
and I understand people
are hard at work on it.
Um, but I've also heard
that the plan
is never to restore
the Flash client,
and I wonder if that means
that IE will be stuck
in the ghetto forever.
It's never gonna get WebGL.
Maybe it'll have WebGL
in IE 10.
But I'm gonna call that "never."
[laughs]
You know, IE 9 doesn't have it,
and IE 8 doesn't have
good Canvas support.
Is IE ever going to get good
Street View from Google Maps v3,
and how would that ever happen?
Raub: [speaking indistinctly]
Mitchell: I'm inclined to say
that's a question for Microsoft.
But... [laughs]
man: But it's not.
I mean, v2 has great
Street View support in IE.
Mitchell: So we--we made
a-a conscious and carefully
considered decision
that we did not want to maintain
two independent
Street View implementations,
um, because--at least
within the API--
because we wanted to--
we felt that in Maps API v2
where we inherited
the Street View client
used by the Google Maps Web site
that we were, um,
somewhat constrained
in terms of the features
we could offer in the API
and that, in a sense, um,
the Street View implementation
in v2
was more a question of embedding
a Street View in a page
rather than actually, um,
building a full-blown
API experience.
And one of the things
that was obviously missing
from v2 Street View
was you couldn't place a marker
a Street View, right?
You couldn't provided custom
imagery in a Street View.
Now if you think
of this in--in--
if you think of
the parallel in Maps,
where would the Maps API be
if you couldn't put
a marker on a map, right?
It was so fundamental.
Um, and you know,
as a team, uh, we, um,
you know, we--we're focused on
JavaScript development,
um, and we felt like
to achieve the kind of things
we wanted to do
and be able to meet
the cross-platform, you know,
commitments we've made,
and particularly to deliver
across all the mobile devices,
which was a big focus of v3,
we had to do--
we had to sort of,
um, take jump
to a Web-based solution.
Now what's--what's,
you know, difficult
is obviously right now, um,
HTML doesn't give you
quite the same degree
of kind of graphical,
um, fluidity
that you would--you know, that
people are used to in--in Flash,
and you know, WebGL
is certainly our--
our great white hope for that.
Um, I don't imagine that,
um, we will--
uh, you're correct to say
that we don't have any plans
to resurrect the Flash API.
And I think, um,
we've seen, you know, a small
amount of demand for that
but certainly not enough
to justify
what would be
a significant effort
in terms of, um,
both skill set,
you know, resourcing,
um, maintain the two things,
keeping them in sync,
meaning that whenever we want
to introduce one new feature
we have to re-implement it
in two, you know,
twice in different ways.
Um, my hope is, um,
that WebGL will gain
a significant degree of momentum
that Microsoft, um, do feel
it would be worth
implementing it in IE.
man: 10.
Mitchell: Sorry?
man: In IE 10.
Mitchell: Yes, in IE 10.
Um, so in the meantime,
I think, um, you know,
there are things we can look
at doing to, um, potential--
to potentially improve
the experience in IE 9.
One, um, thing also we can do
is, um, we can improve
the experience
using Canvas
to a limited extent,
and IE 9 does have
Canvas support.
And some of--of our first,
uh, implementations
of HTML Street View
were Canvas-based
rather than, um, WebGL-based,
so there is some hope there
that we can, um, at least
improve the experience,
if not make it as good as WebGL.
But to a certain extent
I also feel like, um,
just from
a-a technical perspective,
as a company we look
to drive the Web forward,
and, um, there's a limit to
the amount of which I want to--
or I'm comfortable
sort of pandering
to, um, data technology, right.
I'd like to--I'd like to be part
of the movement
to push the Web forward.
And if we can make
a case for, um,
if we can make the case
for WebGL stronger,
um, then I think, you know,
I'd like to do that.
man: Uh, well, then
I guess my last question is,
the Web site is currently
using the Flash version.
This is awkward.
I feel like Google hasn't made
that decision very consistently
that, you know,
if the right decision
for Google Maps's Web Site
is to use Flash,
isn't the right decision for
my Web site also to use Flash?
Mitchell: So this comes back
down to the, um,
you know, the question,
as I mentioned,
of what do you expect of an API
versus what--what do you expect
of the Web site,
and um,
clearly the, uh,
the focus for the Web site
has been, up to now,
um, you know,
just broad availability, right.
Um...
man: I want broad availability.
Mitchell: Sure. Sure.
But at the same time, you know,
we don't feel like we can offer
the features we want to offer,
um, in the API
and deliver what is actually
a, you know, an experience
that allows you to do
flexible and interesting
and new and creative things
that aren't just dropping
a Street View into a page,
um, if we stick with,
um, with the Flash-based client.
So I think that, um,
I-I--the--the Flash-based client
used by the Web site,
um, is essentially,
um, frozen now,
um, and I think that, uh,
it is--it's inevitable that
at some point that will change,
um, and in a sense
we are just a little ahead
of the curve there.
man: Thank you.
man: Hi, guys.
Thanks for taking the time
to come talk to all of us.
I actually have
a bunch of questions,
so I'm going to periodically
step away from the microphone
so other people can talk.
[laughter]
man: Um, but, uh,
all of my questions
are pretty much regarding
the Places API,
so the rest of you
can take a nap
or drink some water
if you'd like.
Um, first of all, I noticed that
there was a mention that--
and there's API support
for check-ins on the--
the Places API,
and that that information
is used for ranking.
And I was curious
if you could get
into a little bit more detail
as to, uh,
that check-in functionality
as well as what
other services are feeding
that check-in information into
the ranking of the Places API.
Mitchell: So right now
the--the check-in service
that Places API has
is essentially a way
that developers
can signal check-ins to us
in order for us to factor that
into the rankings
we deliver to them.
man: Mm-hmm.
Mitchell: Um, it is unrelated
to, for example,
the check-in feature
that was recently introduced
in Latitude,
um, because the check-in feature
in Latitude
is associated with
individual Google accounts
rather than specific API
developers or API applications.
Um, I--
right now, um, if you--
if we have no, um,
if we have no check-ins,
like, if you haven't
submitted check-ins
or a relatively low volume
of check-ins
through the Places API,
your rank is based
purely on the same algorithm
that's used for Google Maps,
and that algorithm is, um, uh,
takes signals from
a wide variety of sources,
and, um, you know, check-ins
are one such source.
So, um, there--
we do expect that you'll get
reasonable ranking
that will actually
be well-suited
to check-in applications
even without providing
check-in signals,
but it will be sort of
a generic check-in ranking.
It won't be specific
to your application.
So if your application
is targeting a very specific
type of business,
um, you won't necessarily see
those types of business
prioritized over others,
which is what you will see
if you, um, if you submit
those check-in signals to us.
man: And I think the tail end
of that question is--
there are obviously a number of
Google or Google-backed services
that do offer
check-in functionality.
Are those check-ins flowing
into the Places API,
or is the Places API
only going to use check-ins
that are explicitly made
through the Places API?
Mitchell: The--the
check-in-based ranking we do
is per application.
So, um, we don't--
we don't aggregate check-ins
across applications
because we don't want
one rogue application
to be able to gain...
man: Mm-hmm.
Mitchell:
the ranking algorithm.
So, um, the--the ranking--
the re-ranking you'll see we do
is based purely on the check-ins
that you have submitted to us.
man: Okay.
Though there is some--I think
you just mentioned also earlier
that there is some level
of global check-in data
that was used, right?
Mitchell: The--there is, um,
so Google has a check-in product
built into Latitude...
man: Mm-hmm.
Mitchell: and that is available
across all Android devices now--
it comes as part of Google Maps
and Google Places on Android--
Um, and that is generating,
you know, check-in information
that Google uses
as a-a ranking signal
for its sort of--
for the ranking algorithm
used across all of its products.
Um, it's, um, so essentially
it's just part of
this broader ranking scheme
that takes in all number
of different signals.
So, um, it's not--
it's also not--
man: So Latitude check-ins
are for Google.
Mitchell: I should mention,
though, that the--
that ranking algorithm
is not real time
in the same way
that Places API are.
So we take ranking signals
from Latitude
and various other sources,
and we take them in aggregate
to figure out
which places are popular,
but we don't do things like, um,
figure out that there's been
a sudden increase in check-in
signals from that service.
It helps us to understand
which bars are popular
compared to other bars,
but it doesn't help us
understand
that a game has just started
at the ballpark,
which is what
the Places API can do.
man: Okay, so Places API
is a real time--
Places API check-ins
are real time
affect the ranking
of your services...
Mitchell: Yes.
man: whereas in services
like Latitude,
and I don't know it Hot--
I guess that is now part--
Latitude and Hotpot are one.
SCVNGR--do those also flow into,
like, this global ranking
even though it's not real time?
Mitchell: No, because SCVNGR
are a Places API partner,
so their ranking--their check-in
signals will only affect
the ranking
of their own application.
man: Okay. Great.
man: Thank you
for being here, guys.
Um, this question
wasn't answered by your team
last year or the year before,
but maybe this year
you guys can answer it.
Um, I'm a GWT user,
and, um, I'm stuck in v2
because, um, there haven't been
bindings programmed
by the Google team for v3,
and we received word
from the GWT guys
who had done it previously
hat they probably
wouldn't be doing it
and don't expect it to happen.
I'm wondering if maybe
you guys will reconsider,
since I'm stuck in v2...
[laughs]
or you can at least
impress upon the GWT team,
the guys who are doing
the GWT Google API stuff,
to move on that.
Raub: I would say put a feature
request on the issue tracker,
'cause that's our best way to
track interest in these things,
and it's certainly something
that is possible,
and so if we see that
there's great interest,
we can prioritize that.
man: [speaking indistinctly]
Raub: [speaking indistinctly]
Okay.
Well, then we're taking that
into consideration.
man: [laughs]
Raub: [speaking indistinctly]
man: Okay, question number two--
um, I'll start with, uh,
probably a stupid one.
So I'm sorry, I did miss
the announcement yesterday,
so I may ask questions
that you answered already
earlier at this conference.
But there was a mentioning
of listings providers.
I was wondering--
it's sort of like
a throwaway sentence at
the bottom of the requirements,
like, you will need
to show that.
Could you go into
a little bit more detail
as to who
the listing partners are
and what kind of data consumers
of the API will need to display?
Mitchell: If I were to, uh,
give you the complete list
of listing partners,
we would probably
run out of time. [laughs]
man: So these are people--
these are companies
that you've received listing
information from, I believe...
Mitchell: Right. So--
man: So it's not
like advertising
or a monetization strategy.
Mitchell: So we--we license, um,
uh, we license
local listings data
from an extremely large number
of sources globally.
Um, one of the things that, uh,
we see as a-a key strength
with this API
is--is our global coverage,
and so to achieve that, um,
we have to work with
a very large number of partners
around the world.
Um, in some cases
those partnerships, um,
uh, require that
attribution is shown
for the companies concerned
when their data is used,
um, and to assist
in--in doing this
we provide
that attribution string
with the place search results
in those cases.
Now this isn't always the case.
In the U.S., for example,
it's not the case,
but it is the case in the U.K.
and Canada and Australia.
Um, so we would deliver that
as an HTML string that contains
the wording, um, "agreed"
and a link to their site,
um, and we just ask
that developers include
that sort of--
you know, for example,
at the bottom of the listings,
um, just underneath,
um, in a similar way
that you have the copyrights
at the bottom of a Google Map.
man: [speaking indistinctly]
man: Go ahead.
I don't want to dominate.
man: I don't either. [laughs]
Um, so with polygon feature--
or polygon editing, um,
we can edit the outer boundary
but not any interior boundaries.
I'm wondering
if that's on your radar
to allow editing of holes
within a polygon.
Raub: When a hole
already exists,
or when, like,
when it's a solid polygon,
and you want to add a hole?
man: Um, okay, make this
a 2-part question. [laughs]
Raub: [laughs] Or both.
man: Yeah, let's start with--
with whether one already exists.
Raub: Um, so we don't have
poly editing yet
in the v3 API,
um, but I assure you that if
you have a hole in the middle--
when we do have the feature, if
you have a hole in the middle,
you'll be able to edit
those points as well.
In terms of adding a hole,
I'd say it's not
something that--
that I haven't thought through
such things,
how you would
do that necessarily.
Um... maybe.
Do you have another...
Mitchell: Yeah, um,
also it's worth mentioning,
we have, um, stated publicly
we are working on
poly line editing,
um, and so it should be coming
fairly soon.
I think, um, when you look
at the list of v2 features
that we want to bring forward
to v3
and the things that are stopping
people from moving v3,
that's one of last
remaining things.
Um, I'm certainly open
to--to looking into ways
we can do, you know,
we can implement adding holes.
My initial instinctive
not-very-carefully-
thought-through concern
is that users
wouldn't necessarily
expect to be able to do that,
and so it might be hard to make
it discoverable as a feature.
Birch: Just a general comment.
This is a chat, so you know,
if you're here,
um, if you have questions,
you want to learn a little bit
more about our APIs,
this is a really great chance
for you to come up
and, you know, there's no, uh,
too stupid question
or too hard a question.
You know, we'll do
our best to answer it.
But please take advantage
of the time to ask
about kind of our products.
Just real quick question--
how many people here
have actually used Fusion Tables
in a site?
Wow. That's great.
Um, how about, um, v3?
How many people have
actually developed in v3?
And then, how about--
are you still using v2?
Okay.
Uh, how about Earth API?
All right. Great.
[laughter]
Birch: Yeah, um, okay, great.
Let me guess,
more Places questions.
man: Yeah, well,
actually I should--
I forgot to say this
at the beginning.
But congratulations
on launch of the Places API.
It looks fantastic,
and it's going to be
a great resource for, I think,
a lot of developers.
So just wanted to make sure that
that was clear.
And I just had all these
very targeted questions.
Um, so part of the Places API
is also the ability
to filter in categories,
and I was curious where that
category information came from,
if that came from
the listings providers,
or if that was generated
by the Google system
and how that involves over time.
Mitchell: Um, it was actually
a significant effort, um,
that was not done
by the API team
but done by another team
at Google,
um, to decide on a, um,
a single consistent
worldwide category scheme,
um, and then map all of
the disparate category schemes
from all over the different
data files we work with
onto that category scheme.
So it is a, um,
a Google-specific scheme,
but, um, it--it's one
that has had a, you know,
a lot of thought, a lot of time,
a lot of effort put into it.
man: We have a question
over here.
man: Hi, guys.
I was wondering if you would,
uh, consider, uh,
allowing people
on using the Maps API
in JavaScript or in Android
to control caching of map tiles
so that we could save,
uh, regions
that we knew we would want.
[laughter]
Mitchell: Um, I believe
there is an open issue
requesting--
requesting offline caching.
It's something that
we're aware would be useful
particularly on mobile
and particularly in places
where the network
is perhaps not as reliable
as we would like it to be
or not always available.
There are very specific, um,
sort of
licensing considerations around
that we need to be careful
to protect.
So we can't provide
a-a mechanism
by which you could, um,
aggregate, you know,
large volumes of tiles
and use them outside
of the application.
So if we can find a way to allow
you to pre-cache tiles
such that they are,
um, you know,
um, you're restricted to using
them within the application
in which they were cached,
then it's something
that we could,
you know, we can look
into doing.
But it's not something,
to be honest with you,
it's not something that we have
done a lot of work on yet.
I think, uh, if--
as Susannah says,
you know, a lot of what we do
is driven by the amount
of interest we see on the group
and the issue tracker
for specific things.
Um, so I would say
definitely, um,
register your interest in that,
and if it bubbles up,
then it will, you know,
we will prioritize it
accordingly.
man: Uh, I have a nicer question
I hope this time.
[laughter]
man: Uh, the, uh,
so I--you made some remarks
about, you know,
one of the few remaining issues
that keep people on v2.
Uh, I wanted to hear
your thoughts
on what the current
top priorities are,
what people are saying about
why they can't move to v3.
You might guess for us
it's Street View,
but I'm curious to hear what it
is in your minds and priorities.
Raub: [speaking indistinctly]
Mitchell: Yeah, Susannah
makes a good point,
which is that you're--
the people in this room
are probably in a better
position to say than--than me.
We--we saw throughout
last year--
you know, when we did the--
the graduation announcement
last year at Google I/O,
there were certainly, um,
a reasonable number of people
who felt that, um,
who were disappointed to find
that the features they needed
to migrate were not ready yet,
and it was--it was
a difficult decision.
Do we wait until every single
feature is implemented,
or do we only wait
until the majority--
the features used
by the majority of sites
are implemented?
Um, and we chose to--to go
for the latter route
just because we--we were keen
to get that process started,
to get people thinking about v3
and interested in v3
and working towards it.
Um, and since then we've been
trying to tick off,
you know, one thing
after another,
um, and I think we've made
a lot of good progress there.
Um, you know,
the 45-degree imagery launch
was one of them, for example,
a fairly recent one that...
man: Awesome. Thank you.
Mitchell: Yeah, that
was definitely something
that we were keen to get done.
Um, I'm trying to think.
There was a bunch of things
that fell into this category.
Raub: [speaking indistinctly]
Mitchell: Yeah.
Raub: Travel directions.
Mitchell: Travel directions
wasn't in v2, was it? Yeah.
So, um, so poly licensing
certainly is--is
the one, the--sort of
the one big one,
if you like, that I see.
Um, hang on.
And, um, there are a few things
I should mention, though,
that will never come into v3,
and that's mostly things that
were sort of utility classes
and things that we had in v2
because back when
v2 was launched
there was no jQuery
and suchlike.
Raub: So people in the room--
because this is a chat--
people in the room
who raised their hands
that they're still using v2,
why?
So it's Street View.
We've heard poly editing
and GWT bindings.
man: [speaking indistinctly]
Raub: Yeah.
Mitchell: Yeah,
that was another one.
Yeah, that's since--
Raub: That's done.
Mitchell: Okay, this is
very heartening. [laughs]
Raub: So we'll work on
those things.
man: [speaking indistinct]
Raub: And one of the things
that I think we should also note
is that when we're bringing
these features to v3
we're trying to bring them
better than they were,
so we're not necessarily--
some of the things may be
taking us a little longer,
'cause we're not trying
to do a direct port.
We want it to be better.
So Street View--you're
not happy with Street View,
but to us Street View is a way
better API than it was in v2.
Um, there's--you can do a lot
more with it in the API.
So we're trying to make that
a priority
is to improve the features
that were in v2
when we bring them across.
man: I have more questions,
but we'll trade.
[laughter]
man: So I actually also
have a similar question
to the question before, before,
um, about caching
of the Places API responses.
I didn't see much detail
about it
on the maintenance
description page.
I was wondering if you could go
into more detail
as to how long you can cache,
what the nature of the caching
is, rights granted, et cetera.
Mitchell: Yeah,
so the Places API inherits--
um, the Places API
is just part of the Maps API,
and consequently it's covered by
the existing Earth and Maps API
terms of service.
Um, and the--
therefore the--the caching
restrictions that apply
to Geocoding, that apply
to directions, et cetera,
um, just carry over
into the Places API.
Um, and what
we basically say is that,
um, we understand that it's
important for applications
to be able to cache,
um, small amounts of data,
um, in order to ensure
their application performs well,
um, and in order to, uh,
in order to build some
of the--the features
that we know people need
to build.
For example, it's very hard
to build a store finder
if you can't cache
in Geocoding information
about the locations
of those stores.
Um, what we don't permit is, um,
is sort of bulk offline,
um, download of data
and use of data outside
of a Maps API application.
Um, we don't publish a,
um, specific number in terms of
"you're allowed to cache
this data for x days."
Um, it's something we're
looking into whether we can do,
'cause I-I realize
that would be helpful.
Um, but what you can do
is we do provide a--something
we call a Places API reference,
which is a handle on the place
that is opaque
so it doesn't represent, um,
any useful data
in and of itself,
but allows you to retrieve
updated information
for that place at anytime
in the future,
and we've worked very hard
to make sure those things
are resilient to changes.
So what you--
you are entitled to do
is cache the data that you need,
um, and then as long as you
refresh that data regularly,
as long as you don't use that
data outside of the application,
and as long as if you ever, um,
cease providing that application
or move to a different source
then you dispose of that data,
then that's okay.
man: All right.
Um, uh, I had a question
about Terrain View.
Uh, Terrain View is gorgeous.
Uh, it looks great.
It's a really elegant way
of sort of getting a sense
of the slopes
that are in the geography.
Um, it has a limit
on its zoom level.
You can't zoom in
past a certain point,
um, which is regrettable
because in some
usability tests we ran
users did not understand
that Terrain View
was the reason why
they couldn't zoom in,
and they were just like,
"Oh, I guess I just
can't just zoom in."
I'm like, "No,
just switch views."
But you can't tell them that
in a usability test,
and you can't tell them that
in the world.
Uh, what can we do about that?
Can we switch to Map View
just at the moment they want
to zoom in a little further?
Especially now when you can
recolor the map tiles,
they can look just like
terrain tiles, just no shading.
Birch: Um, so I'll take that.
So I think, you know,
one of the challenges
is that the level of data that
we have is somewhat limited.
And there was
a conscious decision to--
you know, basically every level
that you go down
increases,
you know, "espentially,"
you know, exponentially
increases the amount of data
that's necessary to actually
serve out that data.
So there was
some conscious decisions
about how far down
we want to do that,
and part of it's based on
kind of the overall usage of--
of the terrain layer as well.
Um, so, I mean,
it's good feedback to hear,
and I guess--
man: We'd definitely use
the terrain layer more
if, I mean, really at all...
Birch: Yeah.
man: you know, if we didn't have
this usability problem.
People think they just
can't zoom in,
like, they're just trapped.
Is there--I mean,
how does Google--
I mean, I think
on Google Maps' Web site,
yeah, you just have a limit on
the zoom level, and that's it,
and I think--as a result
I think people don't use Terrain
as much as they could.
Um, can we just glue the map
layer down at the bottom
as, like, if you zoom in
a little further?
I just want regular--
Birch: So you're saying once--
I mean, I assume
you want terrain layers
further down in the hierarchy
as opposed to
once you get to a certain point
you switch back over.
man: That'd be awesome,
but as a fallback,
if I can't get that,
and it seems reasonable
that I couldn't...
Birch: Okay.
man: Uh, yeah,
I just want to switch
to regular old maps.
Microsoft Virtual Earth
does something very similar.
They have a "shaded view,"
which is Terrain View.
But yeah, they also have a limit
on--on how far you can go.
Once you go past that limit,
you wouldn't notice.
The shades just go away,
and they're in a regular map.
Raub: So with the API,
there should be ways that you
can listen to the map-type ID
that has been selected
and then--in the zoom level.
Um, it's possible that you will
lose one level of terrain
if you listen to that
and switch to map
as soon as that farthest
terrain level is available.
man: It's a good idea.
The zoom control
represents you at the--
Raub: Yeah.
man: You're basically
at maximum now.
And maybe I can be like,
"Oh, well,
if you crank it up to maximum,
it gets a little taller."
But it looks like
you can't zoom in
if you're looking
at the zoom control.
And I don't think
we can control that?
Raub: You can't. That's true.
Um, it would be interesting
to see somebody hack this up
in the API because there should
be a way to work around it.
If this is your number one
feature that you need,
the zoom control
is a very simple control.
man: No, it's Street View.
But it's the number two.
Raub: Number two.
But the zoom control
is a very simple control,
and if you want this kind
of custom functionality,
I mean, that's what the API
is there for, is to do that.
And I agree that we're giving
you this limitation.
man: You were suggesting
drawing my own zoom control,
is that what you were...
Raub: If you want.
I mean, if this is critical...
man: Mm-hmm.
Raub: that's one way
to work around it.
And then send us this,
and be like,
"This is what I did. This is
how it should work." Um...
Mitchell: One option--
I know this isn't ideal,
but it may be better
than nothing--
is if you were to switch to one
of the smaller zoom controls,
you won't have the slider.
Um, and I don't know.
Personally I find these days
I don't tend to use
the slider much.
I tend to use
the mouse scroll wheel
or something like that
to zoom in.
So if your concern is that
the visual indicator
of your zoom level isn't
reflecting the behavior you want
or the behavior
you've even implemented,
if you implemented
an automatic switch over
to a different map type
when you reach that limit,
then that's a possibility.
Um, also I think--I believe--
although, you know, I'm happy to
check this for you afterwards--
that the maximum zoom level
for Terrain is fixed,
um, globally.
Raub: Yes.
Mitchell: Oh, okay.
Susannah tells me that is.
So unlike, for example,
Satellite View,
where we had this problem
in the past where
the maximum satellite zoom level
changes as you go around,
and we had
to implement a service
called getMaxZoomLevel()
that actually tells you what
the maximum is at any point.
With Terrain, you know, okay, if
someone wants to go beyond 15,
or whatever the figure is,
then you need to switch
at that point to something else.
man: Thanks.
man: I'm gonna ask
some dumb questions
because I'm here to learn.
Uh, I work in an industry where
we provide our own terrain.
It's usually design.
So some earth modeling software
is going to create a design
for a new whatever it is,
parking lot or whatever.
So in Google Earth,
we'd like to replace
the terrain that's coming in
with designed terrain.
Is that possible?
Birch: Um, so it's not possible,
but it's something that a lot
of people have asked about.
man: Okay.
Birch: So, um,
so I'm gonna ask you
how you want to use it.
So one question is, what--
what format would you expect
that terrain?
Like, how would you like
to be able to bring that in
and have your terrain displayed?
man: Well, we have TIN models
and grid models, so...
Birch: TIN and grid?
man: Yeah.
But we can do multi-resolution
in grid as well.
Birch: Um, and TIN is vector
format, is that correct?
man: Yeah, triangular mesh.
Birch: Yep.
Um, do you ever use any
kind of raster-based map data?
man: Yeah, that's what
we call grid.
Birch: Okay.
So of those two, which would be
more important to you?
man: Um, it doesn't matter.
We regularly go between
grid-based software
and TIN-based software,
so we can raster as a TIN,
um, if we have a TIN source.
Um...
Birch: How big, um...
I'm just gonna pick your brain
for as long as I can here.
Um, how big of a terrain patch
would you typically, uh, have?
man: It can range--we could have
long highway projects
or--or mine projects
or small parking lot projects,
so you know, you could talk
square miles to,
you know, just square meters.
It ranges quite large.
Birch: So could it be that
that one single file
might be too big?
'Cause one of the things that we
provide in Earth and Earth API
is this idea of regionation,
right,
where you have sort of
a progressive--
is that something that would be
sort of essential
to your application?
man: We have some, um, uh,
multi-resolution techniques
and technologies that we already
use in our own applications...
Birch: Mm-hmm.
man: um, that we could serve up,
you know.
Uh, essentially the patch
is at the resolution
dependent on the viewer.
Um...
[speaking indistinctly]
almost as if we could
just say substitute
or--or just give us
that information
in terms of proximity
and do not bother drawing
that--that surface
and let us just pop one
in there.
Birch: And if you had--
I assume that you're talking
about absolute heights?
man: Yeah, this is
all engineered data, so it's--
Birch: And then what would
you expect to happen
at a seam between where
we're providing data
and you're providing data if
there happens to be a mismatch?
man: Yeah, we run
into that already.
Um, we'll have a site limit,
and then beyond the boundaries
of a site,
the engineer doesn't
care much anyway...
Birch: Mm-hmm.
man: So we'll just paste in,
you know, an aerial photo
that's pretty rough
um, from whatever GIS source.
And the user doesn't care
because they're not
going everywhere.
They're just going
on their site.
So that boundary can be rough,
or, you know, you could have
some kind of, um,
uh, cliff edge
or rough, you know.
It--it can look pretty bad.
But they don't care.
Birch: Um, is this something
that you would hope
to be able to use in a Web site
through the Google Earth APIs
or something where you would
have data files
like a KML or something else
that you'd want to be able to,
uh, view in Google Earth?
man: Well, we use KML right now.
We can--we can export to KML
and then augment
the Google Earth view
to show entering data.
So we're doing that already.
The first part of your question,
could you repeat that?
Birch: Yeah, I was just asking
where would you want to use it,
whether it's in a Web site
or in just a KML file.
man: Web sites are fine, because
it has to do with collaboration
of, you know, subcontractors
with contractors and owners
and D.O.T.s
and things like that,
so you know, having it
on a Web site is great,
'cause they can all
collaborate over it,
and they can, you know, point
and talk and what have you.
So from a visualization point
of view it can exist on the Web.
That's fine.
Birch: Okay.
Well, anyway,
that's great feedback.
Again, it's something that we
hear a lot about, and I'd love
to maybe even afterwards talk
a little bit more about,
just use cases and if we were to
do that, what would be useful.
And just in general
for anyone here,
um, we'd love to hear about
what we aren't doing, right.
I mean, people have been
pretty quiet,
so we assume that means that
we're doing everything great,
and you know, we don't really
need to sweat too much.
But my guess is
there's things that
either are really inconvenient
in what we have today,
and you have
to kind of work around,
or there's things
that you really wish
we would be able to do.
And maybe it's the number one
thing on the issue tracker,
and we just need to get to it.
Maybe it's something that,
you know, isn't there at all.
We'd love to hear about it.
Anyway, thanks very much
for the feedback.
man: Yeah, one other side...
Birch: Sure.
tangent comment.
I heard in one of the sessions
you can show real-time data
within Google Earth
through some KML network
called...
Birch: Network links? Yeah.
man: Yeah.
So I'm unfamiliar with that,
so I'll be going off
and learning more about that.
Um, but the comment was made
that you can do that
through Google Maps.
The Google Maps implement
a subsection of the KML.
And I was just wondering
for a map route,
are you just sort of on your own
to do your own thing,
or is there a recommendation
for real-time data
on Google Maps?
Birch: You want to take that
or...
Raub: [speaking indistinctly]
Birch: Well, I mean,
first of all,
you always have the option of
doing things through JavaScript
to create markers, right.
man: Yeah. Right.
Birch: So the feature
that he's talking about
is the idea of network links,
which is basically a little
KML file that will specify--
it's basically a pointer
to somewhere else
that will then specify
a refresh rate
or, uh, you know, under what
circumstances it will refresh.
So just some examples of that
would be, you know,
we have, like,
a U.S.G.S. earthquake map
that allows you to see
earthquakes in the last hour,
last day, and last week,
um, and if you just have
that file loaded,
it's just updating, you know,
whether it's every five minutes
or ten minutes
or whatever
the author specifies.
Um, same thing--we have, like,
a flight--
airplanes and flight layer
where you can actually see
all the flights in the U.S.
and where they are,
um, and that's just being
updated all the time.
Um, when you're doing that
in Maps--
um, yeah, so there are
some differences
and some things
that aren't supported
when you use pure KML,
and that's something that,
um, you know,
we need to do a better job of--
of certain things.
Um, you do have, of course,
the flexibility
that, because it's JavaScript,
you can actually
go off and fetch new data
and, you know, basically go
into the DOM and--
or you know, go and change
those markers
or move those markers
based on that feedback.
Shapley: Or you can
use Fusion Tables.
Birch: Use Fusion Tables.
man: Oh, like a dynamic...
Shapley: So if you're willing
to venture a little bit outside
of your standard KML format,
Fusion Tables is basically
a tabular data format
in the cloud.
When you describe a feature,
you do describe it with KML,
um, and then you can have
other attribute data
as well in that table.
Um, and then you can use
the Fusion Tables layer
with the Google Maps API,
and every time that page loads,
it'll go and look
at your data set and say,
"Hey, what should
I be showing now?"
So if you want to go ahead
and use
the Fusion Tables SQL API to
change the data in that table,
dynamically...
man: Okay.
Shapley: then every time
that page loads
it'll show what
it should be showing.
man: Now what kind of refresh
rate are you talking about
that would be acceptable?
I mean, I can go to 10 hertz,
and I don't think
that'll be a good thing, right?
Birch: Yeah, so it is
only on refresh,
or can you as a developer say,
"I want this to be, you know,
updating every 15 seconds."
Madhavan: It's always live.
Shapley: No, you need
to reload the page.
Madhavan: On the browser
you got to do it.
man: [speaking indistinctly]
Shapley: For a couple seconds,
yeah.
man: [speaking indistinctly]
Madhavan:
[speaking indistinctly]
Raub: Yeah, we, um...
We implemented a-a map using
the API in Fusion Tables in KML,
all of it,
um, for some of the disasters
that occurred in Australia,
and so we had to actually
reload the--the--
I think we were using KML
at that point--
but reload the KML files,
and same thing if we had been
using Fusion Tables,
we would need to reload
every five minutes
and worry about caching.
man: Okay.
Raub: So it's not built in yet.
One more dumb question,
again, 'cause
I'm here to learn--
so for instance, like, Google
Enterprise, Google Premier,
and then there seems to be
some separation between
maybe what you guys are doing,
and maybe that's
a different group
that's Premier and Enterprise,
and there's some,
maybe some catching up
one needs to do to the other.
And it feels like I might be in
the Premier, Enterprise space.
[microphone feedback whines]
man: So I just need
to figure out what, you know,
for someone like me
who's trying to figure out
how to work with Google
where's my entry point?
Who do I talk to?
Chu: So I--I'd say it does sound
like Google Enterprise would be
the right entry point,
so to your first question, like,
kind of what's the connection
between kind of the consumer
and Enterprise offerings like...
man: Yeah.
Chu: Obviously it's kind of
a very cohesive team
and really the--the goal
of the Google Enterprise team
was literally, you know, people
saw the consumer offerings,
had kind of more
businesslike needs
and needed, like,
an SLA technical support,
more advanced kind of, um,
quotas and whatnot,
um, and we wanted to be able
to support that, right,
and take that same technology.
And so if you look at,
for instance, Maps API,
uh, the consumer
and then the Maps API Premier
offering, right,
the real differences
are kind of the terms,
um, in terms of enabling
kind of internal sites,
uh, paid offerings--
Uh, you can do that
with Premier--
and that's not something that's
really in the consumer offering,
uh, 24/5 technical support,
99.9% SLA,
and then, uh, for instance, in
many of the Web services you get
kind of much higher
quota limits.
So typically you get
around 2,500 per day
on the consumer offering,
and 100,000 per day--
and you can upgrade from there
in terms of both queries
per second as well as numbers.
So that's just say, I mean,
the goal really
is to kind of offer that
additional level, right,
in terms of kind of
functionality as well as, um,
and so things like
private Fusion Tables layers
was another one that seemed like
it was more
of an Enterprise use case.
In terms of kind of the, um,
engagement model,
that's another one that, um,
like right now
in order for us to scale
on a consumer side
we really need to kind of, you
know, interact through forums
and kind of the starring
of feature requests and bugs.
But, um, on the Enterprise side,
um, we def--
if you go to any
of these products,
they have kind of like
a "Contact Us" form
that directly goes
to a sales rep
who's happy to kind of reach out
either through e-mail and phone
and directly interact with you
in terms of kind of
what your needs are.
We also have
a sales engineer organization
that can kind of help--help make
that technical decision for you.
Um, so that would be--
I would recommend that
as--as a great engagement model.
man: Okay.
How am I doing?
man: Great. All right.
Shapley: We've got
a new gentleman in the back.
Maybe he can go ahead
and ask his question.
man: Question as well.
man: It's a Fusion Table
question.
man: Okay, so, uh, the, uh,
the current Android Map app
is--is vector-based, right,
at least in the U.S.
Is that right for that data,
or is that worldwide yet,
or is there a plan
for that to go global?
man: [speaking indistinctly]
man: It's worldwide.
When will developers be able
to have access to that same--
instead of tiles
but having vector,
you know, vector-based mapping
inside their apps?
Mitchell: This is specifically
Android--Android apps?
man: Well, Android, initially,
but then across platform,
iOS and other...
Mitchell:
So the Android Maps API
is part of the Android platform,
the Android
development platform.
Um, that's not a-a--
that's not something
that us folks here
are directly involved in.
Um, but I know that, um,
that there are, uh,
there are discussions
in progress as to how to bring
the vector rendering
into the Android Maps API.
It's obviously something
that developers are demanding
and that we want to provide
Android developers with the same
freedom and flexibility
that they see
in the native application.
As far as the Web-based APIs
are concerned,
um, the benefits--potential
benefits and opportunities
of vector rendering
are very clear,
um, but we are at the mercy
of--of browser performance
there right now.
So it's something that
we're keeping an eye on.
Um, it's something that, um,
we're all excited about,
the possibilities there,
um, and as soon as it reaches
the point
where we feel we can deliver
an acceptable user experience,
um, in that way,
then, you know, it's something
that we'll--
we'll start looking at.
man: And just
one follow-up question--
regarding the Elevation API,
is there--is there still
an effort to continually
get granular, more fine-grain
data on the Elevation side,
or are we at an area
where it doesn't make
feasible sense to go deep--
you know, more accurate data?
Birch: Um, so that's something
that, you know,
we're always trying to get more
data and get more updates.
Um, so I think, you know,
um, it's really a matter
about getting access
to higher-quality data, right,
so depending of where you are,
like, you know,
globally the resolution
isn't as good as in the U.S.,
and then in certain areas
we'll have
kind of like what's happened
with--with imagery, right.
It kind of starts off
with a lower resolution,
and then over time
we can potentially
get higher resolution in set.
So, um, you know,
I expect that quality
to be getting better over time,
especially as we get access
to new sources of terrain data.
man: Okay, thanks.
man:
It's a Fusion Table question.
When are we going to be able
to do OR queries
and--I know it's number two
on the issues list.
Shapley: Can--can you say
a little bit more about
how you would use it?
man: Like, for, um, plotting
contaminants on a map,
like, where contaminate
equals mercury OR PCPs
for this county.
Shapley: So--so...
man: It's issue number 49
on the...
Madhavan:
[speaking indistinctly]
Shapley: It's, yeah, it's right
there at the top of the list,
and that hasn't escaped us.
We definitely see it there.
[laughs]
Mitchell: Just one
other comment on that.
Um, as far as plotting
on a map is concerned,
you can add more than one Fusion
Table layer to a given map,
so you can add up to five Fusion
Table layers on any one map.
So that is a way you can say--
you know, you can have
one layer for one contaminant,
one layer for another.
Another approach,
which is sort of an extension
of the same idea,
is that the dynamic styling
of Fusion Table layers
that we announced yesterday
would allow you to,
for example,
say "I'd like to render
a Fusion Table layer
"of all the contaminants,
"and I'd like to render
the mercury in this color,
and I'd like to render"
so on and so on and so on.
man: But that's also eliminated
the five, though, right?
Mitchell: So it's limited
to five style rolls
within a single layer
and up to, um,
I forget right now--
five layers, one of which can be
styled with up to five rolls.
So by combining
the two approaches,
I think you can get to nine.
[laughter]
man: I have one more--
I'm sorry--one final--
Mitchell: For
the folks at the back,
there are a lot of empty chairs
if you'd like to...
man: Easy question, I think.
Um, Places API mentions
that if you set up
billing information
you can go up to 100,000
requests per day,
uh, and presumably
if you start exceeding that
there will at some point be
a billing structure
and pricing system.
I was curious
if you could shed any light
on what that will look like
when it's announced.
Mitchell: The requirement
to enable billing
is actually primarily driven by
the need for us to strongly
identify developers.
Um, we did have a, um,
a previous offering called
the AJAX search API
that offered some
local search features.
Um, we had some difficulties
there with, um, abuse,
like specifically
anonymous abuse.
So we wanted to be a little more
careful this time,
so we asked people
to go through that--that check,
um, just so that we can provide
the kind of levels of quality
that we'd like to provide.
We don't actually have
a current plan
to, um, to implement billing.
I think we're more interested
at the moment in just--
um, if there are sites
that are generating
more than 100,000 Places API
requests a day,
um, they sound like interesting
strategic partners for us,
um, and we'd be interested
in--in talking to them about,
you know, what they're doing
and what their needs are
and ways in which
we can work with them
and they can work with us,
and that's the model
that we're taking right now
in terms of what to do
if people come to us and ask us
or those kind of volumes.
I think--okay, um,
one last question.
Yes, go for it.
man: All right, this is
a transition from v2 to v3.
Um, the Street View overlay
and map.ad overlay--
um, how do I do that in v3?
I just want the blue lines
on the map just to show up.
I had two lines of code
to do it in v2,
and I don't know how
to do it in v3.
Mitchell: So, yeah.
So right now the--the lines
appear automatically
as you drag Pegman,
but you're saying
you'd like it to appear--
man: I'm not using your Pegman.
I want my own Pegman.
Mitchell: Yeah, that's--I've
seen a few requests for that.
Um, so I'm pretty sure, again,
that there is an open issue
for that, so just flag it.
But you're quite right.
Right now it's not possible.
man: Okay, that's why
it's not there.
Mitchell: Okay, thank you
very much, everybody.